c'est parti moi je suis prêt à aller on
assure tout de suite face et pas bonjour
je m'appelle marie christine je regarde
votre émission régulièrement et à chaque
fois vous vous moquez de maxime gainey
qui auraient une vie sentimentale proche
du néant
donc je voulais vous dire que si vous me
l'avez je suis prête à faire un geste et
intérêts s'est intéressé aux on voir un
petit peu ce qu'on peut à faire avec
elle la joue macho maintenant alors je
vous remercie infiniment chère
marie-christine de voix aider ce pauvre
maxime qui en effet dans la belge depuis
un petit bout de temps et personne ne
comprend qu'il aura regardé il est beau
garçon il est propre et tous ces vaccins
sont à jour
comment en est on arrivé là pourquoi
dans le grand chenil de l'amour personne
n'a voulu l'adopter
on ya cru à un moment avec kelly vely
maudit dans leur relation a changé mais
aussi maintenant ils sont comme chien et
chat apparaît comme on dirait sur un
réseau social c'est compliqué regardez
ces images c'est très étonnant maxime va
passer d'un grand sourire complice avec
no 10 est à un moment de dégoût total
ce jour là qui lui demandait pourquoi il
voulait pas lui prêter son téléphone
portable
[Musique]
et
[Rires]
[Musique]
oh
est-ce que cet apport est celle
affectueuse mais l'avant des choses
parce qu'il a fait new jersey mythomane
mais bombardier pas prêter votre porte à
croire ce que vous êtes sur des basses
saturent des mof en ce moment oui non
oui voici les sur un bail et en guise
sur un nom qui fait longuet qui fait la
roche c'est cuit on peut avoir un prénom
non non non elle s'appelle marguerite
non crs 3 2 en monnaies ciel ça veut
dire deux c'est le comment une
indication à nages
non mais sérieux juste le prénom et yala
plein lucy lucy taconnet obispo a fait
une chose on lui connaît il a connu ou
celui-ci tient pas il a connu une suite
de rencontres
c'est le grand lequel type qui adopte un
chroniqueur vin comme lequel tine ou
quoi c'est vrai mais rigoureux dans le
caca à partie c'est ça ben j'ai fait
très large et sera connue en europe
il m'apporte
on est parti bien qu en tanzanie là
alors et donc oui pour ceux vus deux
fois
non il ya lu bisou à non égale à 7 soit
au moins la troisième fois si je faisais
pareil
dieng à bâle et leurs élus il n'attend
pas la croix d'impôts elle attend la 3e
minute sur el mahdi ne dit pas mon
prénom bon là je pense que c'est un peu
mal mais on va l'appeler lucioles
lucioles on n'a pas parlé de toi tu es
maintenant on sait que le troisième
rendez vous savez dangereux pression
troisième vendée où il va tenter un truc
ouais alors il va tenter une galoche ça
ouais est ce que c'est une bonne
stratégie de l'annoncer à la télé non
hebbadj à dubaï
maxime est radieuse en tout cas si l'uci
nous regarde sache que maxime va faire
une très grande carrière
voilà dans quel domaine non mais
l'animation je vous le dis pis pour ça
c'est celui pour moi qui a en ce moment
dans tout le parc aux potins sein d un
des plus bel avenir
c'est vrai mais c'est vraiment là je ne
rigole pas je dis franchement on met
bien d'autres bureaux h2o tu me dis que
c'était moi mais c'est le sait le
meilleur actuellement n'a en fait jamais
vous avez oui à qui tu parles
vous avez vingt ans de plus que lui bah
oui voilà si parfois du tout il a 31
noms et ben vous avez 25 en date est
celui moi j'appelle pascal le grand
frère on fait quand même nom même
magazine
un très grand talent mais ça va mais
c'est vrai les gars vous avez d'humour
vraiment des tempêtes passant même en
suisse merci pour ya trois semaines sur
ce plateau nous avions les black eyed
peas et la semaine dernière nous
recevions la chorale seniors 50 peppers
oui le programmateur est schizophrène
alors quand on sait que jean-michel même
pas 5 live sur six comment été reçus ces
nouveaux chanteurs qu'on ne verra jamais
en nrj music awards la réponse en images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mr
[Musique]
non
pas cher en temps je suis fou de ce mec
qui me regardent ce thème auparavant je
t'aime rang battu parce que je les aime
ce mec et il est exceptionnel ça arrive
c'est fabuleux ça vous avez aussi la
spéciale punchline du sniper officiers
de l'émission la fameuse mais qu'est ce
que ce que cette mascarade ça a bien
marché donc le lendemain il la retourne
vers jonathan n'ont rien compris à la
grande déception de jean michel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les cafés de romans c'est ce qui
cartonne le plus en ce moment et vous
êtes vraiment ringard c'est pas au maire
catégorie 1 mais la kalach 29,33 ababou
bea va vous basez connais pas mais je le
dis à moi c'est sûr la balle aujourd'hui
à bah oui mais quand elle va voir vous
connaissiez rien mais pour l'instant les
des étoiles dans les yeux sur l'accord
a3 et la skoda vie tout à l'heure celui
qui a eu la meilleure réflexion c'est
maxime qui dit une nouvelle fois à lui
tu sens qu'il n'a pas d'amis mais qu'il
a envie de parler alors il s'est dit
qu'une corde le senior c'est un bon
sujet pour faire copain copain avec
jean-michel un moment triste de la
semaine
[Applaudissements]
c'est 10 millions d'unités
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
une telle jovialité comme ça on sentait
qu'il se passait quelque chose et on
passe au top et danses tous ces petits
moments qui peuvent se passer que dans
cet asile de fous qui étaient pipés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lourdes j'ai vraiment passé quatre
semaines incroyables une équipe
incroyable des gens formidables et des
gens gentils et humainement enfin bref
pour moi est sorti grandi et bien on est
sortis grandis ben oui oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les saveurs
[Musique]
vincent moscato déguisé en beyoncé
et aussi
[Musique]
bonjour d'ailleurs elle rajoute par
rapport à ce que tu as dix joueurs sous
le sujet dans les deux choses des choses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gens là c'est le programme événement
pérenne ses découvertes
j'allais me retrouver je suis vraiment
les 85 son meilleur tour
faux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
peut pas lui parler ne peut pas égaler à
celle ci non mais franchement pas mais
on est en direct un bien sûr toujours
s'est vite avec mon jean luc ont dévalé
les ordres anton second 12 secondes
après 13 secondes alors
exceptionnellement cette année j'ai
senti une image du top gênant ce qui
écarte demande explications
je vais vous dire la vérité mathieu me
fait de plus en plus peur je sais pas ce
qui se passe la semaine dernière je vous
avait déjà montré sa
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on a une balle au bond pour
suis si fier il avait dit que c'est à
cause d'une odeur d'oignons qui
l'incommodé oui c'est bien la première
fois ce pays les partis en vacances ont
décru à moitié le problème c'est que
j'ai douze images de lui et que je me
désiste pas disparu et là il n'ya pas
d'oignons ce qu'on voit sur mac la salle
du top gênante à mon avis il ya des gens
dans sa tête et je ne sont pas tous
payer le loyer
on va avoir une explication qui inquiète
la suis inquiet
[Musique]
oui
j'en sais rien et même dans le tpr que
j'ai un pote qui était bourré de tics et
oui vous avez un nerveux je pense que
c'est depuis qu'il a son émission c'est
évidemment son cerveau n'est plus assez
oxygénée quand j'ai au contact aussi
dessus pas je sais pas c'est bien tard
et que vous êtes à mon compte n'est pas
bien tu vois c'est sympa mais bon on va
arrêter de se fréquenter
[Rires]
non mais je suis timide c'est la
troisième année qu'on se connaît et
c'est là où en général ça se fait c'est
la première chose qu'on retient chez toi
la timidité d'humilité non moi je pense
que c'est vraiment à cause de son
émission parce qu'on va pas se mentir il
a changé depuis qu'il est devenu
animateur vedette le mec et satellisé il
supporte plus rien alors les critiques
je comprends mais même les compliments
sama grèce
nationale a commencé
merci c'est gentil mais c'est pas toi
[Applaudissements]
merci un peu d'amour avec un méchant à
messac magna syrie les paillasses cyril
et moi enfin bon ben on est 5 e lundi
cheikh la chaîne tchèque syrie dans
l'année bureau et tout ça j'ai moins de
temps pour vous mais vous aime quand
même et la voir très vite beaucoup font
livrer les repas que la direction semble
envoyer killer là parce que tant
qu'homme il est un peu tard je peux vous
passer des déclarations un peu plus
coquines comme ils disent en amour par
exemple est ce que vous voulez savoir
combien d'hommes a connu valérie benaïm
dans sa vie entière moi je le sais mais
12 mai la mnam heures - des fous benhaim
1,3 et naïm maintenant 22 ans fille de
demander
[Musique]
j'ai demandé à mon show ça ce contrat
jour un jour
[Applaudissements]
à
alors ce samedi je ne sais pas ce que ça
va faire plaisir à votre nouvelle
compagne c'est qu'il doit pour garder un
bon gars un peu plus sous mais quand
même a alors tout sourire ça me fait
toujours rire aujourd'hui et j'ai un peu
plus cela nous le maître à bord et on
commence par gilles verdez qui nous en
rappeler une règle essentielle du
journalisme
[Musique]
il faut le laisser tranquille ceux qui
n'ont pas d'infos n'en donne pas ses
règles simples du journalisme après elle
vous kiffe grave mais désormais ce
garçon majeur depuis le début non mais
t'as quel âge mais ni moi j'ai 17 ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour vous benjamin castaldi qui est le
meilleur animateur de ces mois passés
comme seule pensée
[Musique]
fait plus
moi et
[Musique]
tout cela
il viendra nous voir alonso là il va
venir nous voir très prochainement dans
tpm pays dépendant bien s'arrêter
l'humour de ton père mental et le
physique
comme je me dis que c'est toi je trouve
celui qui
[Musique]
l'amour est aveugle c'est vrai que
c'était la première et télé réalité de
nabila et à la changer
c'est fou d'années comme les vedettes
s'est bien rattrapé le bon temps mais
aussi con de l'eau que de face à troyes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
j'aurai un sens
[Musique]
l'accusé droite
[Applaudissements]
les
mais bon
[Musique]
il était enfant emporte la semaine